don't search for wonders for all of them
a union
hey everybody we finally got some
footage of the black order coming for
vision in the mind gem we've seen some
footage of this piece together through
the other trailers as well as way back
at comic-con they've been filming this
this is part of the Scotland stuff
they've been doing because I believe
that's where the prequel comics said
that they went to to just go off by
themselves between the events of civil
war in the beginning of infinity war so
if you're finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get all the
Marvel videos there's even more than
this they just convert a bunch of
characters coming back for Captain
Marvel including Clark Gregg's Coulson
so I'll talk about that too so whole
bunch of Marvel stuff planned in the
next couple of days but the big thing
about this clip like I mean there's a
couple of funny scenes like Groot
sassing Peter oh come on
language like he's like Gollum from The
Lord of the Rings with his little game
machine who knows what kind of video
game that he's playing but look at the
corner of his eye the way he looks at
the screen that's the exact same way
that Gollum looks at the hobbits when
he's really pissed off at them this
scene probably happens right before that
Thor scene that I posted yesterday where
he lands smack-dab on the windshield so
I'll link that video at the end of this
but the real big thing here is Proxima
midnight vs. Scarlet Witch so a lot of
you been asking how big scarlet witch's
parties during infinity war we've seen a
couple scenes with her with vision where
it looks like he's either had the mind
gem already ripped out of his head or
he's getting ready to die at the hands
of Thanos when he says we've run out of
time like that's the end of it Thanos is
getting ready to Chuck Captain America
out of the way even though Winter
Soldier looks like he's running out of
the bushes to try and save them all this
is the first big fight where they just
get blindsided by the black order so
it's Proxima midnight in Corvus glaive
although you don't see him really well
in this footage this is mostly about
Proxima midnight and Scarlet Witch the
thing that the Russos said about this is
they said we structured the scene like a
horror film we try to give each sequence
in the film a slightly different tone
and concept based on the characters
driving that sequence Paul Bettany
himself actually said I think for both
Lizzie and I it's the most exciting
plotline for each of us so far I was
busted out
my cap and we've been running road
mission since nice you got some issues
man I mean apparently you may lose your
stone and your head keeps you alive I
mean what does it mean Thanos is going
to get it so I obviously their plot line
stretches across the entire film but for
the latter part of the film vision is
like the damsel in distress so they're
trying to figure out how to save him how
to deal with the infinity stone use him
as the living MacGuffin to bring Thanos
to them when they're in Wakanda but the
early part of the film is really just
them being Scarlet Witch envisioned
together just dealing with their
relationship so Elizabeth Olsen when
asked about that said oh yeah you know
we kind of deal with that a little bit
early in the film but obviously this is
pretty packed with characters so they'll
give you a little bit of that moment
which is why he looks kind of like he's
human in that hotel room like they've
been living together as a couple since
civil war has ended and they're just
completely blindsided when the Black
Order attacked them but if you're
wondering why vision looks human here is
because he can make himself look like
anything he wants remember the vibranium
body that he has is infinitely malleable
he can turn it into anything so he
chooses to look like this but I think
part of the idea is that he wants to be
more human-like it's a Pinocchio type
thing so that's why he looks like this
when he's with Scarlet Witch mostly for
her benefit but it's sort of him
exploring his own humanity because
there's all kinds of questions about
what's gonna happen to him when he loses
the mine stone do you know I don't know
what this is not really I know it's not
of this world
and powered Loki's staff gave you your
abilities but it's true nature is
a mystery and yet it is pardon are you
afraid of it I wish to understand it
the more I do the less it controls me
one day who knows I may even control it
but early prediction is that they'll
find a way to make you think like he's
going to die and he will seem like he
dies but they'll find a way to bring him
back because in the comics he's self
repairs I think I've talked about this
in a couple videos so he's one of those
characters where you can actually just
do something really crazy in WTF but
because he's a machine you can repair
him you can bring him right back in
Cherie has technology that's way more
advanced than the AI that was used to
create Ultron which is basically what
you need to repair vision she's got all
the gadgets you got all the tricks but
let me know what you guys think of this
fight between Scarlet Witch and Proxima
midnight I don't think that she's gonna
be one of the Black Order members that
ends up dying I do think that the
Avengers will be able to kill a couple
of the Black Order but just like most of
the Avengers will probably survive two
Avengers for I think that some of the
Black Order will survive two Avengers
for because the way that josh brolin and
the directors talk about Thanos as
children is is that they're very
important to him like Gamora is still
his favorite child they're still at the
basic level just tools for him to
accomplish his goal half of humanity
will still exist when I'm done that
seems like an arbitrary thing like he's
erasing half of all life in the galaxy
why would then it'd be half of the
population of every planet equally I
think lines like that or in the movie to
make it feel more relatable for people
who are big comic book fans like they
want you to feel like Earth is gonna die
but really this is the entire universe
we're talking about trillions upon
trillions of lives you go back and you
watch some of those interviews that they
did earlier they make a lot more sense
now like this is all back from d23 when
they were talking about the movie I
can't can I say no I wouldn't say too
much but you can say as much as me hey
let me just say this like every other
Marvel movie it doesn't end well for the
superheroes wait till you see this next
one everybody have to do
not everybody know that hey can we
rewind that part yeah can we were you'll
cut that that's not who is there anybody
in infinity war do you get to meet that
you're excited to meet am I in trouble a
little dude I don't I just move on I
wouldn't I would like to meet let me
know in context now what you think that
they were talking about when they were
doing these now like they try to give
away as much as possible without really
giving away stuff the idea that everyone
dies isn't so far-fetched but I don't
think that's actually going to happen I
do think in that moment he was just
joking around a little bit and when josh
brolin talks about all the cable thanos
jokes obviously we've already seen some
of that in that Deadpool on cable
trailer but what'll happen is is I'll do
a Captain Marvel video next sorta like
Avengers infinity war Captain Marvel
Coulson returns video explaining what's
going on with that movie the kree-skrull
war and why it's a big deal that Ronan
the accuser is coming back remember it
takes place back during the 90s so
anybody who's died in the relative
present day of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is fair to come back which
includes Ronan the accuser so that video
should be up in the next couple of hours
but there's a whole bunch of other stuff
that's happening this week leave all
your bonus video requests in the
comments below while you wait for
everything click here for that trailer
where Thor meets the guardians of the
galaxy if you are a big Dragon Ball fan
I did a video for the finale so you can
click here to watch that thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you